I'm just gonna go ahead and assume
everybody called who the witch was gonna
be right Goutham second episode of the
fifth season and this one was a little
bit disappointing certainly compared to
the last one it was I don't want to say
wheel spinning but it was one of those
that's more about sort of getting the
pieces moved into certain places than
was actually moving much forward I mean
the main thing that actually kind of
developed at all was the stuff that went
on with Selina and I have mixed feelings
about it for a couple of reasons so
that's my general thoughts I'm gonna get
into spoilers pretty quickly since I'm
getting these up several days after the
air I assume most people who care have
seen the thing by now so um I don't I'm
not especially fond of like kind of the
fodder gangs that got tossed in to this
one and like I was really looking
forward to how the characters that we
know and have been established are
faring in this world and I feel like we
got tossed a bunch of nobodies this time
that if they were supposed to be people
either from before references to the
comics I didn't get them maybe they were
too deep a cut in either case you know
the the gang with the with the kids and
the and the ghosts and yeah it just it
was a lot of that wasn't clicking for me
Barbara was good I mean III like Barbara
ticked off I think that's when Barbara's
best so I was all for that I was all
about that then okay so the the IV thing
first of all I'll just reiterate at this
point I don't like this IV especially
like there have been three IVs young IV
current IV and what Liz and I have come
to term middle IV and we love middle IV
a lot this IV not nearly as interesting
and what I had hoped for is because
there was like this build-up to the
reveal of her despite all the hints
pointing to it was gonna be it was just
kind of her like I'd really hoped that
they were gonna go like say go
lines of some of the more inhuman kind
of incarnation she's having the comics
you know maybe her skin would be green
maybe she'd have like the vines actually
coming out of her you know it's sort of
edged across just like one of those
looks one of the more one of the less
human looks and they just kind of didn't
and mio well there's there's a wasted
opportunity plus the fact that I'm stuck
with this one now as far as what happens
to Selena I have mixed feelings about
where when I saw where it was heading I
was like I don't like this at all the
way it actually played out was slightly
better than out then what I was afraid
of I still don't really like it though
so here's my big problem with this with
the whole with the whole premise
apparently now being that this seed is
going to not only help
Selena recover but also sort of bring
out her worst elements to set her up to
be a villain form you know the proper
world of Batman where she'll be Catwoman
and all that um you know I get that but
here's what I don't like about it Bruce
was the one who sought it out Bruce was
the one who brought it back to her Bruce
was honestly the only one who was told
in any terms even the vague ones that he
got what the consequences were gonna be
in other words Selina kind of got robbed
of agency here in turn and I don't just
mean in the immediate because yes she
doesn't make the decision I want to take
it but like this is going to affect the
entire path of her future life and I
feel like in some ways that Rob's her of
the agency of dis of who she gets to
decide to be and that bugs me especially
because I like this version of Selina
and I would have bought this version of
so I was like I would have bought that
there could have been an event where
this version of Selina would have simply
chosen to not walk the straight and
narrow as Bruce does and feeling like
it's it's more forced onto her I don't
like that as a general premise again
it's not as bad as it could have been
cuz she does say you know she does
decide to take this thing so there she
has a little bit Ava agency there but
like overall I still feel like it robs
her a little bit and then like some
stuff that as I said feels
wheel-spinning like I feel like we learn
nothing new with Edie even with the
Riddler and I feel
they're just padding that out at this
point they got to get to wherever that's
going and beyond that it was just a lot
of it felt like it was reiterating stuff
from before like Gordon has another
conversation with the mainland about how
they can't get somebody like yeah we did
this last time and like there's a whole
bunch of people going to the cops you
know for safety and security yeah we
covered that last time like I it feels
like it's reiterating a heck of a lot of
stuff that was made pretty clear in the
last episode or at least clear enough
that it didn't need to be reiterated
completely so I don't know this wasn't
it wasn't bad it was not a bad episode
but given that this is a short season it
is the last season this is the kind of
getting the pieces moved into the right
place borderline filler episode I'm a
lot more forgiving of when a season has
22 episodes when it's a shortened season
like this I don't want to see stuff like
this find a way to get the pieces moved
where they need to be for later in a
more interesting and entertaining and
absorbing way than this it felt it felt
very much like a transitional episode
from the setup we got before to whatever
is going to happen next time these were
the things that had to happen to allow
whatever's next but it didn't feel like
much beyond that so yeah a little bit
disappointed with this particular
episode of Gotham but you know hopefully
it bounces back cuz Gotham
like I say Gotham can't have these kinds
of episodes from time to time and
usually it is setting up something that
is gonna be a lot more fun later but as
I said I'm Way more forgiving of that
when we're talking about a longer season
of television and this isn't that so not
yeah not in love but in any case have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something out in the comments let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's buttons and links
including one to the patreon if you want
to support me in that way it would be
greatly appreciated but there's other
stuff to check out as well if you want
to and if you don't that is okay because
at the end of the day folks you are the
council and I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]